let's go to the u.s now where an iranian
man has been charged with plotting to
murder john bolton the former national
security adviser for donald trump during
his presidency iran does not currently
have an extradition treaty with the
united states meaning the suspect known
as shahram pusafi cannot currently be
taken in by the u.s authorities well
joining me now live from washington is
john bolton thank you for being
with us um first of all i mean what do
you make of the
charges against this man
well they sound uh
perfectly uh clear to me i think this is
a plot by the iranian government
against a former official of the u.s
government uh i can say i can't say a
lot of things but i could say i'm not
the only one that the
that the uh ayatollahs in tehran are
trying to assassinate so this is the
kind of government we have in in iran
and i think it should tell everybody
including the government of great
britain why this is a government that
trying to resuscitate the 2015 nuclear
deal is a is a terrible mistake
strategically uh for us and for our
friends in the middle east
so i mean you have no question or no
doubt that he was working on behalf of
the
iranian state i mean who else you
mentioned other people who else do you
think they were targeting or trying to
kill
well i don't i don't know about this
particular individual
there are others who it's been reported
in the press it's really not for me to
get into the specifics
but it's not just former government
officials it's uh it's private citizens
in the united states and this is this
has been something the government of
iran has done
uh from the time of the islamic
revolution in 1979 when they seized the
american embassy and kept their
diplomats hostage to the time that
through uh an element in lebanon that
later became part of hezbollah they blew
up the marine barracks
in beirut they've attacked our troops
and our diplomats through shia militia
surrogates
in iraq and syria
this is a murderous
lying regime it's an enemy of the united
states and we need to treat it that way
but the chance of this individual ending
up in an american court is pretty remote
well uh for now but we have our ways and
uh we'll see what happens i think it's
important that this uh document this
evidence was unsealed by the court
uh here in washington this morning i
think uh it helps
the citizens of the united states and
really in in the world as a whole see
exactly what the nature of the regime in
tehran is
uh and to think that any commitment they
make would be honored uh is a clear
mistake and i hope in britain and and uh
in the european union that people
realize that
and so you you think it is possible to
you that he could
he could uh face trial in the united
states
what because you'd get a hold of him
somehow or what i mean because or
because of the change in the regime or
what
well you know american law enforcement
is uh is very efficient and as our
cousins to the north and canada say you
know the mounties always get their man
we may get this one
and you were i mean it was no secret an
advocate of maximum pressure on iran and
escalating sanctions and
even
asking i think at one stage for the
military options over the nuclear issue
do you still have that
view
well i've gone beyond that i did before
i was in the white house i think the
only way we're going to get peace and
stability in the middle east is to get a
different regime in tehran
and i have long believed that
their nuclear weapons activities and
their support for terrorist groups like
hamas and hezbollah and the houthis in
yemen
and their direct acts of state terrorism
like going after american citizens on
american soil are all part of the same
mix this is the nature of the regime
this is the regime's ideology this is
the threat we all face and
as i say i hope the information that's
been made public today helps inform uh
citizens so that they know more fully
what the nature of the iranian regime is
and what the threat is i mean but seeing
regime change in iran could lead to all
sorts of
of
difficulties and problems given that
they are you know developing a nuclear
weapon like the ones we have now unlike
the ones we have now
but i mean we saw what happened in iraq
yeah well if if you can imagine a worse
regime than the one we have in tehran
now i'd like to know what it would be
look so the eu
uh is trying to salvage the
the nuclear deal the 2015 iran nuclear
deal you
clearly don't think that's the way
forward
the 2015 deal was a mistake when it was
made the iranians never should have been
allowed any capability to enrich uranium
the deal has not gotten any better with
age the biden administration has spent
close to 18 months on its knees all but
begging iran to let us back in the deal
it's a huge strategic mistake i hope uh
there's a new government coming in
britain i hope britain's view changes
from that of france and germany which
have been mistaken for many many years i
think
people need to wake up to the nature of
this regime they're getting perilously
close to a nuclear weapons capability
which in their hands threatens their
neighbors in the region and really the
the world as a whole
and the potential they would give that
to terrorist groups uh without having to
deliver it via a ballistic missile
should worry all of us how close do you
think they are
well it depends in part on how close
their cooperation with north korea is
since they're both benefiting from the
pakistani nuclear
entrepreneur aq khan who sold them the
initial uranium enrichment technology
who provided them with weapons designs
uh and because we cannot be sure that we
have full intelligence as to what iran
is up to i mean if anybody has learned
anything from prior experience don't
count on knowing what some foreign
government is not doing because
we have been limited in our capabilities
in iran for many years and the idea that
the 2015 deal opened iran's nuclear
program up to real inspection is a total
charade and just on the issue of the the
charges against this individual um
do you still think there's a threat
against you do you
have you
changed your security and are you very
much aware of a threat against you still
well it's not not what my opinion is
it's the the opinion of law enforcement
and the intelligence community i've
been granted the secret service
protection again by president biden
since last december i think
obviously that was the correct decision
i'm grateful that he made that decision
uh and it will continue as long as they
deem it necessary it's not not my call
quick word on donald trump uh this fbi
raid on his
home what did you make of that
well i i don't know what to make of it
because i think there's a lot of
information we don't know and i think a
lot of people on both sides trump's
defenders trump's opponents have gotten
a little hyperthyroid about it
i do think it has obviously generated
considerable attention and i think the
attorney general merrick garland would
be well advised to speak publicly to
this question one one way we could
eliminate some of the uncertainty would
be for donald trump to make public the
search warrant that he was given so that
people can see what the fbi was after
yeah that would be interesting is there
a sense though do you think that this
could help donald trump politically
enable him once again to claim a witch
hunt that it's the establishment against
uh donald trump
sure that's what he's doing now and uh
and that's why i think that you know in
the normal course of things in the
united states as in great britain law
enforcement does not speak when it's
conducting a criminal investigation or
when it's conducting a prosecution it
speaks only in court filings and court
appearances that gives others an
advantage because of that silence but uh
there is there is a procedure in this
case i think it should be the attorney
general when it's a matter of public
interest like this that he can reveal
more than is uh commonly the case and
and i think it's justified here i think
it's important for him to explain and
and to back up why the justice
department uh took this step and just to
make one point clear obviously the
justice department didn't do it on its
own
under the fifth amendment to the
constitution they had to go to a federal
court uh they had to show that there was
cause for a search warrant
and a judge a magistrate in this case
had to approve it which is also what
happened so
they followed the constitutional
procedures and and if they feel that
that they were right i think they need
to get out and explain why and just a
couple more jason miller came on this
program last night i'm sure you know him
saying he thinks donald trump will
definitely stand uh what do you think
i don't think ultimately trump will run
i think he's afraid of losing i think
for trump the worst thing in the world
is to be known as a loser and he doesn't
want to lose in 2024 i think he'll try
and be a king maker in the republican
party's nomination process and
uh and he may well have success in that
but when it gets right down to it he
will talk about it incessantly for the
next many months but i don't think
ultimately we'll be a candidate and just
finally was nancy pelosi right to go to
taiwan
a hundred percent right it's the right
thing to do the united states should
stand by taiwan should not put up with
this provocative behavior by china i
think people all along the periphery and
the indo-pacific around china are
worried about chinese efforts to
establish hegemony in that space they
look to the united states and frankly
they'd like to look to europe too uh to
see to see us make common cause with
them taiwan is the the focal point but
many others feel threatened as well so
this is this is an issue for the rest of
the century whether cha type whether
china's belligerent behavior
will be countered or whether it will be
successful